souvenez vous le 19 décembre dernier en
direct du carrousel du puy-du-fou
amandine petit miss normandie 2020 été
couronnée miss france 2000 21 sous les
yeux de 8,6 millions de téléspectateurs
mais france 2021 est et restera miss
normandie soirée magique pour la jeune
candidate de 23 ans mais qui n'a pas été
aussi belle pour toutes les miss à
l'instar par exemple d'april benayoun
miss provence 2020 qui sera éliminé en
finale face à elle jusqu'au bout de
nombreux français ont voté massivement
par sms pour soutenir la jeune femme
sauf qu'au même moment sur internet un
flot insupportable d' insulte anti
sémite envahissait les réseaux sociaux
suite à son passage où elle évoquait sa
religion
ma mère est croate et mon père estrella
italien des insultes d'une extrême
violence qui a pris la découvert à sa
sortie du plateau
trois mois après les événements april
benayoun a décidé de s'exprimer sur ces
terribles message elle est avec nous ce
soir
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'être là et
merci à jean veil avocat d'april
benayoun est ce que ça va aujourd'hui ça
vous a marqué cette histoire oui bien
sûr c'est déjà à l'aventurier français
marc tu as mais quand on fait cette
aventure on s'attend pas à voir ce genre
de commentaires très très violent sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est le problème
des réseaux sociaux parfois c'est vrai
qu'il peut y avoir une violence
horribles et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
tweets vraiment qu'on n'a même pas envie
de lire ici qu'on n'a même pas envie de
repasser qui était vraiment affligeant
de bêtise
est ce que vous l'avez appris pendant
l'élection qui avaient des noms actions
de ce genre ont pas daigné appris le
lendemain parce que le corps de
l'élection on a un petit peu ailleurs à
bien sûr on a envie de profiter des
derniers moments avec les autres
candidates
donc je l' ai appris le lendemain par
des amis qui m'ont envoyé les messages
ça a été dur pour vous cette polémique
le lendemain oui ça a été dur mais parce
qu'on s'y attend pas en fait on s'attend
pas du tout à recevoir ce genre de
message quand on participe à miss france
it à vous a blessé
oui bien sûr que ça m'a blessé
aujourd'hui ça vous donne envie de
parler d'être encore plus présent dans
les médias ou plutôt de vous dire j'ai
plus je vais apparaître plus il va y en
avoir et donc gg ça vous fait peur
non parce que je sais que déjà j'ai reçu
énormément de soutien par rapport à ça
je m'attendais pas à une telle vague de
soutien et
non j'ai envie d'en parler alors je me
suis très peu exprimé au début parce que
je n'étais pas prête à ça quand on fait
cette aventure on s'attend pas à ça donc
j'étais pas du tout prête à parler de ça
mais maintenant avec le recul je suis un
petit peu plus prête à débattre dessus
qu'est ce que vous pensez des certaines
personnes qui disent que peut-être que
ça aurait joué dans le l'issue de
l'élection miss france
bah écoute et déjà ce que je peux leur
dire c'est qu'on le saura jamais c'est
vrai on peut partir le soir voilà on
peut se poser la question
le nombre de fois qu'on veut on le saura
jamais et moi je pense pas parce que de
toute façon je pense que je serais pas
allé aussi loin dans l'aventuré
si c'était vraiment problématique je
suis quand même arrivé première dauphine
donc moi je pense pas et j'ai pas envie
de me poser la question sur sa jv relais
oui j'ai une question pour m veille
notamment l'antisémitisme c'est un délit
et d'ailleurs et une enquête ouverte
pour injure à caractère raciste
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas
remis en cause sur le plan légal
l'élection de miss france vous auriez
peut-être gagner non je pense que je
n'aurais pas gagné il y avait un aléa et
par conséquence j'ai recommandé à april
de chercher les voies et moyens qui
étaient les plus efficaces pour éviter
premièrement d'être l'héroïne d'une
procédure qui dure très longtemps les
procédures pénales durent plusieurs
années elles sont aléatoires et il m'a
semblé que on pouvait probablement
choisir une autre voie qui est la voie
civile
j'ai droit à tout petit cours de droit
de droit je dirais la chose suivante pas
d une demi-feuille et prenez des notes
nom prénom prenez des notes profession
des parents parce qu'ils y mettent la
loi sur la presse de 1881 bresse a
beaucoup changé depuis 1880 et notamment
avec les réseaux sociaux qui finalement
organise un anonymat qui permet
d'insulter alors il ya une nouvelle loi
sur le sur la haine qui permet de
sanctionner et la recommandation que
j'ai formulées à april qui va avoir à
peine 22 ans d'avoir mené une procédure
qui pourrait durer cinq six ou peut-être
dix ans elle a autre chose à faire et
donc qu'il m'a semblé que l'on pouvait
trouver non pas des recherches
policières pour savoir qui étaient les
gens qui utilisaient lâchement les
pseudonymes puisqu'ils n'ont même pas le
courage d'affronter le fait que les
annonces leur nom et ce qu'ils font et
nous avons engagé une procédure qui
commence simplement maintenant nous
avons demandé
à twitter de nous donner un certain
nombre d'informations qui nous
permettront de calculer quelle est le
bascule
tous les vêtements des gants ces
informations on appelait on appelait ça
la semaine dernière et en arabe on aura
le résultat le vin c'est surtout ce que
vous êtes en train de dire là c'est
aussi surtout pour protéger a pris vous
dit elle va pas y rester avec cette
histoire pendant 2,5 disons comme vous
venez de dire c'est ce que moi je j'ai
recommandé à recommander april de faire
une procédure civile directement contre
twitter ça twitte heures fait de la
recette avec ses actions d'affichage et
par conséquent c'est l'argent qui a été
perçu par twitter que je vais essayer de
récupérer pour april c'est une bonne
idée de mieux que de faire des
procédures pénales
3 le 23 mars nous allons avoir des
indications du tribunal la possibilité
d'avoir des informations chez twitter de
savoir quelle est la recette que twitter
a fait et ensuite nous demanderont le
remboursement du préjudice qui a été
super merci et va merci maître veil de
nous dire tout ça a appris aujourd'hui
voilà vous êtes passé à autre chose ou
pas du tout oui je pense qu'il faut
passer à autre chose au ch'ti c'est
important on peut pas rester dans cet
état d'esprit alors c'est vrai qu'au
début c'est très difficile les premières
semaines c'est très difficile mais après
il faut qu'on passe à autre chose on a
plein de propositions après une séance
donc on les saisies et vous avez eu
plein de propositions depuis ouais nous
alors alors chez du mannequinat je
comprends pas pourquoi ça arrive pas
voilà quoi c'est curieux et empêcher de
la science d'accord c'est très bien bon
bah en tout cas je trouve que le là là
vraiment la démarche de l'avocat et de
vous mettre veille je trouve que c'est
c'est très bien joué we are ou parce que
c'est vrai comment ça va permettre à
april de passer à autre chose on peut
avoir cette affaire pendant 2,5 10 ans
et je trouve que 2,2 de s'attaquer
plutôt à twitter sans vraiment voilà
face à l'attaqué mais sur les recels etc
je crois que c'est une très bonne idée
voilà j'espère qu'en tout cas on va
avoir des nouvelles et j'espère que ça
se reproduira plus surtout dans une
élection ou dans une autre émission de
télévision parce que c'est surtout ça
c'est vrai que ça cc c'est pas possible
sur vous dans des émissions comme ça
populaire où est vraiment ça fait ça
fait de la peine et ça a gâché la fête
de miss france qui était une bien belle
cérémonie et raja les un mot parce que
madame schiappa ministre a également
saisi le parquet donc il y a
parallèlement une procédure pénale
procédure pénale se poursuivra contre
les gens qui ont effectivement utilisé
75 ans après la fin du nazisme des des
insultes absolument insupportable
portable on ne peut pas dire en 2020 que
tonton adolf à oublier d'exterminer
april c'est une situation inexplicable
et intolérable et c'est le problème de
ces le problème n'est des réseaux
sociaux en général
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est en train
de changer n'est ce pas on a vu qu'en ce
qui concerne tardivement certes trump
sont à sur son compte à être son compte
a été fermé
de la même manière
je crois que les un autre groupe
américain a lutté contre un groupe qui a
été disque qui a été dissous par le
gouvernement français en raison de son
extrémisme à droite
vous parlez des migrations identitaire
je parle de génération identitaire
absolument et je pense que il y a une
police à faire mais ça des réseaux c'est
à l'état de le faire et il appartient
aux victimes
en revanche d'obtenir réparation du
préjudice financièrement